[Music]
tammy faye
what'd you do hello mother this is jim
baker
my husband
it's all part of our mission to help
people anyone who's hurting or they feel
like they've been left out
god has planned for us what'd he tell
you to do this time
jim will preach and i'll sing
now god has a voice in this fight who's
he fighting
liberal agenda homosexual agenda faith
isn't political
you can't talk to him like that jerry
falwell is a powerful man tammy faye
she's a firecracker jim
if everyone watching could double their
pledge
just for one month god loves you
he really does
[Music]
we're not doing anything wrong though
is that a question
[Music]
tammy and i are undergoing the most
vicious attacks
serving god don't feel like it should be
a money-making opportunity
you know when i saw that clipping with
my face on it i thought for a second
that you were proud of me
oh tammy faye you follow blindly in the
end
all you are is blind
i just want to love people cry every
night the devil's coming for me tammy
can we talk about satan leader jim
steve is a patient of aids i can't look
at this you need to get her under
control
i built you an empire i built you an
empire
some people they're just hurting so bad
and we just need to love them
i want to put my arm around you and i
want to put my arms around you tammy
i won't go for it looking in the
rear-view mirror of my life
this is who i am
[Music]
you